[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: Kimberley Chambers
is one of only six people
to ever complete the Ocean's
Seven challenge, a grueling
collection of open water
swims around the world.
What's surprising is that she
was not an experienced swimmer,
and before she began
this challenge,
she was told she wouldn't
even be able to walk.
Can you tell me
what happened when
you got into your accident?
KIMBERLEY CHAMBERS: I
was on my way to work,
and I slipped down my staircase.
And I hit my right
leg on a ceramic pot.
An I hit it at just
the right point
where it started to swell.
My next memory is waking
up post-surgery 30 minutes
from amputation
from the knee down.
I remember the surgeon
telling me, we saved your leg,
but we don't know what, if any,
functionality you'll ever have.
And that really was I think
a really defining moment
in my life.
I could have gone down a
really deep, dark hole.
I could have accepted
that, but I told myself
I was going to prove them wrong.
And then once I was
doing physical therapy,
I got into this routine.
Being able to move
was pretty magical,
and I wanted to do more.
And that's how I
got into swimming.
I knew how to swim, and I
knew that that would make
me feel a little more free.
So I started swimming at a
pool here in San Francisco.
I got in, and I just loved it.
I just felt really normal.
I was like, yeah, I'm
just another swimmer.
And it was the beginning
of this passion.
LAURA LING: After years
of physical therapy,
Kim not only learned
to walk again,
but she put all of her energy
into accomplishing the Ocean's
Seven, which consists of
swims like the English
Channel and the Cook Strait.
The swims are as
long as 26 miles
and in temperatures as low
as 53 degrees Fahrenheit.
Some swims took Kim just
four hours to complete,
others nearly 20 hours.
Tell me how swimming has
become a ritual for you.
KIMBERLEY CHAMBERS:
It's something
that is really sacred to me.
I can't imagine my
life without it.
I start my day at
4:15 every morning.
I train in a pool for
about an hour and a half.
I then go for another
swim in the bay.
LAURA LING: Tell me about one
of your more challenging swims.
KIMBERLEY CHAMBERS:
The most challenging
swim so far for me has been from
Northern Ireland to Scotland.
SPEAKER: Kim is in a
huge fight right now
against this nasty current.
KIMBERLEY CHAMBERS: I've
been in for five minutes,
and first jellyfish.
I was stung hundreds of
times, over 200 times,
by these lion's mane jellyfish.
I did make the swim.
I did finish it.
I don't really remember.
LAURA LING: And you're still
getting back in the water.
KIMBERLEY CHAMBERS:
I feel so transformed
by these experiences.
I don't think I ever
really appreciated
what my body could do for me.
For these swims, you
don't get a gold medal.
You don't get a cash prize.
You're not competing
with anybody,
and you're really
competing with your mind.
LAURA LING: Do you think
that this ritual of swimming
saved your life in some sense?
KIMBERLEY CHAMBERS: Absolutely.
the ritual of swimming
is so important for me.
Every day, my body gets
to be immersed in the bay.
I see a variety of
birds out there.
I see seals out there.
You have these real amazing
interactions with nature
before most people are awake.
And I can't imagine my
life without it now.
LAURA LING: In this next
episode of "Rituals," click here
to see how Jason Silva
creates his "Shots of Awe."
JASON SILVA: The
disconnection from distraction
gets your brain daydreaming.
When you're in
daydreaming mode, you
start to do a little bit
of the lateral thinking.
So you start connecting
this to that to this
and you start to go
through the a-ha moments.
LAURA LING: If you'd
like to continue
to see more stories
from around the world,
we need you to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.